we've lost a lot of family members here
on the street Andre as of late reality
star Tim Norman sentenced to life in
prison for his role in a murder-for-hire
plot that led to the Fatal 2016 shooting
of his nephew Andre Montgomery
okay Andre huh this is whole Pebble we
use fresh pepper they were co-stars in
the long-running series welcome to
Sweetie Pies and Norman has maintained
he had no involvement in his nephew's
murder I'm glad you're coming to help me
bro I think the difficult in having a
family business you can't find them the
reality series which ran for nine
seasons on the Oprah Winfrey Network
chronicled life behind the counter at
Sweetie Pies a soul food Eatery in St
Louis owned by Norman's mother a former
backup singer for Tina Turner who goes
by the name Miss Robbie my son Tim
tackles everything from supplies to
managing our employees people will come
by the restaurant and sit and watch me
my mom argue all day so somebody said
hey man this would be funny if you guys
try to put this on TV in a statement
prosecutors said Norman portrayed one
image to the public but there were more
Sinister intentions lurking underneath
we lost the entire family of balance he
was arrested in 2020 the charges
conspiracy to commit murder for hire and
conspiracy to commit wire fraud with
Norman taking out a 450 000 life
insurance policy on Montgomery then
arranged for his nephew's murder Andre
is like one of the beats in my heart and
it's gone
Norman was found guilty in September but
we could have closure if somebody would
tell who did this to Andre they set him
up it was somebody he knew because he
got a phone call and he went outside and
when he got outside they shot him he
wouldn't have gone outside for a
stranger following his conviction the
restaurant closed Robbie told customers
thank you all so much for the many years
of support and just a week before his
sentencing Norman continued pleading his
innocence on social media telling fans
thank you for all the prayers I'm still
in disbelief the caption hashtag
innocent I know a lot of people you know
have said I've done things in their past
that I regret the prosecution adds
although Andre's family was robbed of
their loved one hopefully this result
will provide some measure of peace and
justice for them
foreign
[Music]